so hopefully everyone's had a chance to
swing by the rapid booth out there if
not swing by later on that we can do
kind of a really deep dive into the area
that you're interested in all my slides
are available online so you don't have
to worry about you know taking pictures
of them or trying to quickly go through
and figure out you know the pertinent
information actually all on our rapid
website so rapid that AI will take you
to our website under Doc's overview you
can actually download the full slide
deck and start looking at it I'm not
going to do all the slides that are in
there there's like 70 some slides and I
don't have that much time so but
everything's out there every release we
produce a new slide deck so you can go
back and look at things also you can
check out all our documentation
everything you want is available on our
website including all of the stuff of
how to get Rapids how to install it
getting started will take you to a page
where you can figure out if you want
Conda install docker you know click all
the boxes that will give you the magic
code to copy and paste into your browser
or into a command line so with that said
let me dive into pretty much a little
bit of history and then we'll get into
rapid so big data has been around for a
while if you can't tell by my gray hair
I've been doing this for a while I was
actually doing it back before there was
the term big data we called it data
warehousing very large databases just
you know I have a ton of data type
problems federated databases and then
came along Hadoop this was great because
then I could just throw everything into
a giant lake quarry it I didn't have to
worry about well so to worry about
schemas but you didn't have to worry
about him as much the problem was
it was slow I guess at the time when it
first came out we considered it fast
because we were working on even slower
systems but it still took hours to do
queries and it would go out run a piece
of the query save temporary results next
thing would read those temporary results
which was great because it gave you
fault tolerance you didn't have to spend
a lot of money on your machines and then
came SPARC and when SPARC first came out
I was amazed at how fast it was compared
to Hadoop it loaded everything in memory
it still took hours to run queries and
then in video we set around saying okay
this is cool let's start accelerating it
because I want things faster and years
ago all we would do is really focus on
accelerating an analytic so let's take
XG boost and make that fast the problem
is we realized that it wasn't solving
our problem because it didn't address
the fall and to end it just shifted
where the bottleneck was so accelerating
different analytics caused this problem
that we were still doing a lots of
writes within the GPU realm moving data
in and off the GPU is kind of one of the
most costly processes you can do it
takes a while to move it because you're
limited by PCI bandwidth or however it's
connected bandwidth so we really want to
get rid of this step of having to copy
data every time we wanted all of our
applications to be able to share the
same data just past pointers around and
luckily Along Came Apache arrow to find
this nice column or store we said hey if
all of our stuff here's the column or
store I can now run kind of my ETL and
I'll just give the machine learning
folks a pointer to that data they know
the format I don't have to copy it don't
have to convert it move it off the GPU
back onto the GPU life will be great and
following that approach we've now gotten
down to you know a hundred X faster than
where we were over spark which was 100x
faster over Hadoop light
is great we can actually start doing
things at reasonable speeds right I did
a lot of spark stuff and I would say
okay here's a cool model I would code it
up I would hit run and about ten minutes
of waiting I would start thinking you
know if I did that model differently I
would get this answer and I would start
coding up the new model and by the time
the one model finished running I'm like
I can't remember when I was doing there
let me just start this new one and see
what that is and it just led to just
repeating things over and over and not
really being productive so let's just
jump into how fast rapid really is so
this is an example where we were taking
mortgage data from Fannie Mae so this is
a collection of multiple years two
hundred gigabytes of data on disk which
doesn't always translate to 200
gigabytes in memory because things
explode and you can start converting
formats
so we have to load the data even though
it comes from Fannie Mae for some reason
they cannot spell bank names correctly
so we have to adjust all the bank names
then we roll do this 12 month rolling
window over the data to look at how well
mortgages are doing and that produces
three new columns we then take those
three columns pass them into XG boosts
we train this model and then we say okay
four new mortgages are they gonna fail
yes or no kind of the standard thing you
would do right I'm assuming everyone in
this room is a data scientist or
understands data science and and math so
we wrote this all up we coded it on 20
nodes 30 knows 50 notes and a hundred
nodes of spark and then we also ran it
on two of our larger Nvidia boxes one
with 16 GPUs and then 5/8 GPU boxes so
as you can see we'll just jump all the
way to the other side here we're even
100 nodes spark is 3221 seconds
you know that's plenty amount of time to
you know get up go have lunch and come
back and you finally get your answer we
did it all in
213 seconds so basically enough time to
get up go get a cup of coffee and come
back to your desks and there's the
answer our goal was to be able to load
all the data and have your prediction
faster than spark could even finish
loading it and when we achieve that goal
so we're happy this is kind of what what
type of performance you can get I've
heard people kind of say yeah I really
don't need performance my model is set I
just train it every now and then and I
give it out to customers and I'd have to
say that your competitors probably do
care about performance if you have a
model out there that people are using
and I can iterate real fast and come up
with a better model your model may not
be kind of being used that much longer
we also don't just sit around saying
okay we did something let's move on to
the next problem
we constantly improve our code so our
goal is to make things as fast as
possible we start off we're saying let's
make it work first and then we slowly
iterate so over the past couple months
we've actually reduced a lot of these
runtimes down and basically for you you
just use the code the next release
sun-lee is you know another 10x faster
and you just magically get the benefit
of all this hard work that we're doing
under the covers we have a lot of stuff
coming up which should cut even these
numbers right here in half and again
performance is critical and I'm
borrowing some slides here you know the
fastest way to win to data science is
speed user experience and really being
able to iterate really really fast if I
can try things at the speed of thought
I'm like oh let's see what this does run
it and get an answer tweak it I mean you
can now answer questions faster and
better I worked with a customer where it
would take us a week to come up with an
answer and whatever answer came out at
the end of that week was what we want
list because we didn't
time to do it again and then we've
proved to the customer that their answer
was totally wrong so it's like well I
know it's wrong but I still have to go
with it because I don't have another
week because everything changes in time
so our goal is to make things fast so
let's dive into kind of the core rapid
so here's what the open system currently
looks like you do everything in pandas
for all your basic ETL stuff data
loading munging cleansing everything
else you then pass it over to psychic
learn for your machine learning
applications if you do any graph
analytics network X is probably your
favorite maybe maybe not
then PI torch and then a lot of
visualization tools are out there also
does that make sense people say things
that are right or wrong or and then you
can use tasks for scalability we love
all of these approaches and all of these
api's so we've said we love the api's
let's keep the api's but totally redo
everything else so if you notice kind of
our kind of library stack looks almost
the same
we just have KU DF instead of pandas so
if you know pandas you can program in ku
DF your code probably 90% of it won't
have to change from what you have you
just changed an import statement
it runs likewise we have cout ml that
adheres to everything psychic Learn does
in rias probably is on our team and they
advise us on stuff so they look it over
ku graph if you like network X we have
the graph package does everything in
there and of course desk we're just
stretching desk over farther so everyone
know about desk who doesn't know about
passing us everyone else Matt Rocklin
was here the other day he could have hit
him up for all your desk questions and
he's leading the desk effort
allows you to scale your Python
application across multiple nodes so
once once that you set a cluster up and
you distribute stuff basically you
program as you were in pandas it has
data frames they're just distributed
across things so it allows us now to
scale I can write an application on one
node and then easily expand that to a
hundred nodes a thousand nodes I think
there are customers going beyond a
thousand nodes we love to ask but dance
could use in some improvements that's
where you see X comes in because desk is
based on doing TCP sockets which we know
are not the most performant so you see X
is now you can think of it as a topology
aware framework so it knows how machines
are connected and it will optimize
communication for you once it's
integrated into desk you don't have to
know about it at all you just run the
latest desk and it will figure out what
you have and run kind of well right now
we're getting about 20x improvements
just by going to UC X we should have
some real published benchmarks numbers
coming up but this will now allow you to
start you know you have your basic
approach wrap this is just the same
thing just faster likewise you scale out
with desk you'll now scale out with
rapid desk and you see X and you'll just
get that much more performance so my
goal is to make this talk the most
exciting and also boring because it's
like yeah I know that already
so cou TF the life of a data scientist I
used to sit next to the data Science
Group on my old project and I never saw
them work all I would see them do is sit
around and talk about movies they would
type some stuff and then they would just
sit around for a half hour just goofing
off I'm like wow I'm working my butt off
and they're just having fun
but yeah you kick off a job and you wait
20 minutes and then it comes back and
you're
oops typed something wrong you try it
again and you just iterate that cycle
now since things run so fast well we're
actually putting them to work so
companies are actually getting their
money's worth out of a data scientist
now cuz they're not drinking as much
coffee or goofing off as much and I
didn't get to hear about movies anymore
data stack Python layer we use scythe on
to go from Python down to C and then
everything under the covers is really
C++ and CUDA for the users you don't
have to know anything about GPU
programming anything about you know how
its paralyzed and distributed anything
else all you have to know is Python and
you just create a data frame and it's
magically on the GPU you type your
command you know data frame dot max or
something to find it and it just runs so
it's all hidden from you unless you
actually want to dive down into it
you're welcome to get the code add
things to it play with it it's all open
source if you break it well that's your
fault
so ETL is really the backbone of data
science I mean I want to be able to read
things in within pandas I think there's
probably like 500 functions there are a
lot and we are slowly working to get
them all in there and maintain you know
as accurate adherence to that API as we
can so we're coming for user-defined
functions we use number it jet compiles
it down to something on the GPU so you
say ok you know your library doesn't
have this I want to do this data
conversion I will write it JIT compile
it and then I can now call it with
inside my code again how fast is it
doing merges joins group bys when you do
in data exploration those are kind of
the backbone now maybe counting and
averaging is really the backbone it's
where you always start with you know how
many items do I have
and it's odd that the bigger the dataset
the faster speed up you get with GPUs we
have lots of cores more data just makes
us happy so 100 million rows doin emerge
870 X faster no that would be you know
from 870 seconds down to one second to
do a merge
likewise for sorting and grouping one of
the things we really did also is focus
on IO we don't want to have to read data
elsewhere and then import it we want to
have all of our readers just suck the
data right into the GPU and do
everything on the GPU so we have a CSV
reader part K reader or creature JSON
Avro we have a whole list of things
coming up basically it just bulk loads
data right off a file right into the GPU
and then we do all of the column column
our identification data type
identification everything on there as
you can see we are reading this is 1.9
gigs in pandas and in the coup d f1 so
29 seconds versus 2.3 seconds if you
want to make it faster specify the
number of columns than the data types of
the columns and then we don't have to do
that and then you're suddenly cutting
that down to you know one second we are
working very hard to improve that so
probably by summertime those numbers
will be cut in half depending on your
machine if you have you know your box
connected up to storage you want to slow
things someplace else this really won't
help you we also found out that a lot of
real-world data is strings people really
never did strings on GPUs just because
they are odd sizes and you never know
how much data to allocate but we created
an entire string library so you can load
all your strings in there eventually
we'll have full reg X
pretty much everything you want I'd like
to do a lot of you know sediment
analysis and other things and strings
and they're slowly working towards that
but again you can do well to lower to
upper fine split you know substring
extraction everything you want is now
one to GPU accelerated and fast machine
learning how many people here do machine
learning like machine learning Wow
traditionally what you would have you
have a ton of data you would do some
type of dimensional reduction figure out
your feature set you do some iteration
cross validation of it and then you
sample down you say okay now I have my
sample size not can run my machine
learning on it there is a talk at our GT
CDC conference last month where some
folks from Capital One said this was
their approach but now with GPUs and
rapid they can actually process all the
data just as fast so you know why do you
have to sample anymore just take it all
spread it out across a lot of GPUs run
your machine learning algorithm get your
answers and it helps because you can do
better prediction in the same amount of
time actually it was faster than the
amount of time they were spending with
the sampled version the stack looks very
much the same
Python scythe on down to all the
algorithms building a primitives library
once that perimeters library is fast it
has allows other developers to build new
algorithms just using those primitives
so if you want to do matrix multiplies
there's that function you can just tie
it into other things and new algorithms
will just pop out a lot faster then
there's - ties into it numpy
so a large collection of algorithms and
more to come I think you Maps up there
and today I want to go to the you map
talk yeah we're getting a lot of good
success from you map but you know rain
too far as decision trees
I still like decision trees because
they're they're easy to understand when
you see the answers like okay I figure I
can see how you got here versus some of
the kind of deep learning approaches
like an answer pops out I don't know how
I got here
here's an answer K nearest neighbors all
your kind of PCA and dimensional well
component analysis hope winner if you're
doing time series stuff there's a video
out on YouTube so we're working closely
with Walmart they want to predict what
stores need what product so they're
using Holt winter and kind of a Rhema to
look at the time series of stuff and
then predict what's going to be going on
the future so they can better plan truck
routing so there's a nice video where
they explain everything a lot better
than I do but check it out so here's a
comparison of using DB scan in Python so
you load the data into data frame
you call fit you call predict you get
some nice pictures and then if you want
to see how it's done in rapid the only
thing really changes you know import it
qml so instead of scikit-learn qu ml and
everything else looks exactly the same
that's what I mean by this can be a
boring talk look I changed five
characters again using this you get some
incredible speed ups depends on which
analytic you're doing how much data and
all but things just run fast
this is a partial view of the road map
hopefully by March everything will be
running on multiple GPUs typically we
start with making it work making it work
on a single GPU and then we spanned out
to having it work on multiple GPUs it's
actually a lot of complexity on getting
things distributed past one node but our
plainest have all of that done and more
by March when we hit version one soku
graph is our graph analytics process how
many people do graph analytics or
familiar with graph analytics so ku
graph again incredible speeds we can do
about 500 million edges on a single GPU
everything is done via data frames so
you can create these large property
graphs and data frames pass that right
into the graph analytic since it does
talk data frames I can do things like
take all my data I can say okay now I
want these columns to be my vertices IDs
I can come up with like page rank scores
or other graph centrality scores and
then I can pass that data right into a
machine learning algorithm I don't have
to convert back because I get a data
frame in and I return a data frame and
machine learning all the Kumail stuff
takes data frames we all talked the same
language so now I can quickly build
additional feature sets that I pass on
to machine learning surprise surprise
the stack looks the same right Python at
the top python is you know we love
python it's the first-class citizen
within graph there's a couple other
large open source efforts going on that
we are slowly bringing in together and
kind of tying in to this ecosystem so
graph blas comes out of UC well Texas
A&M Hornet came out of Georgia Tech we
tie into gunrock got a UC Davis
so if you were using one of these other
products eventually it's all gonna be
rolled in there so we're working with
all those folks make sure that happens
since I managed the graph team I kind of
and more excited about this piece than
the other ones
Dante is sitting over there is on the
the machine learning team so if you have
machine learning problems questions find
him so we have a lot of clustering
graphs are great for well cyber for
finding anomalies recommendation systems
social network analysis you know predict
which people you should connect with
next on face book whole series of
centrality measures path finding you
know if you go the airport and you want
to do the Traveling Salesman problem of
how many hops will it take to get from
this Airport to the next one and the
cheapest amount of time so breath foot
search and shortest path algorithms are
out there Network X is not known for
performance so it makes our numbers look
incredibly good we're fast but we're
comparing with something that's
incredibly slow so when I say it's now
32,000 X faster I have some benchmark
codes that runs a lot of network x stuff
and I actually had to get rid of some
files because I didn't want wait six
hours for them to finish so louvain is
this agglomerative clustering algorithm
where it just iterates over and over
looking for groupings of folks and then
it says okay here's what's in the same
group but we are getting significant
speed ups so PageRank this is kind of
the classic Google algorithm of you know
recommending websites ago - it's based
on the fact that popular websites have
other popular websites that point to
them so popular people have popular
friends so it just iterates over
you know my popularity is based on the
popularity of my neighbor so it's a
strange iterative thing so we took the
high bench numbers this came out of
Intel so we created this data set up to
16 billion vertices so this is 300
gigabytes of data threw it in there said
okay how fast will our PageRank run we
got it down to 30 1.8 seconds
most of that time is really going from a
data frame into our matrix to run and
then back out we ran the same thing on a
hundred node spark cluster this took
fifty seven hundred seconds so roughly
96 minutes versus half a minute now
those are also things that you notice
when you necessarily have free time to
to think about it unless you want to
kick the job off and go to lunch I have
had customers that say they like it slow
because they could kick something off at
night and when they come in the morning
it would be ready and they wouldn't
really have to do anything else again
our roadmap is to slowly work towards
being you know multi-gpu everything I do
need to update this with a bunch of
other algorithms deep learning the
people in here do deep learning as well
so we go through DL pack and what this
allows us to do is you can have
everything inside of rapid and just pass
those pointers off to pretty much
anything so you go through chain er
you've got two pi torch we all speak the
same language now or we can just
translate it into the right thing
dante's talk later this afternoon we'll
go into more depth than that but you can
now load your data into rapid do a lot
of clean up prep and then say okay it's
ready and just call your deep learning
algorithm you don't
to like write it back off the disk and
then start up another program to do it
um we're also developing a lot of other
libraries so we have a spatial
processing library so if you have like
road networks and you want to say here's
a bounding box around this area
tell me everything in there any type of
GIS work we're now supporting that ku
signal signal processing basically you
know this comes really out of the what
is it free radio effort and so basically
if you have signals radar signals FM
signals a.m. whatever you can start
analyzing them beyond just do an FFT and
it also runs significantly faster than a
Sai PI signal we have plans to expand
that to do a lot more we also have to
cross filter data shaders all
visualization tools we have a quants
thing coming on we have a bunch of other
efforts so we're slowly expanding to
cover the full gamut of libraries that
you need to actually do your data
science and display your answers if you
go by the rapid booth you'll notice that
nvidia is not really you know mentioned
too much there because we really want
this to be an ecosystem and partner
controlled thing so we're doing a lot of
the work but we want people to
contribute and use it and join in with
us so we have a lot of contributing
partners we have a lot of people
adopting it a lot of open source efforts
that we work with we also have a bunch
of projects that are building things on
top of rapid nucleo blazing sequel
streams these folks have kind of adopted
it and thus say okay actually now
build big systems blazing Divi folks I
talked to all the time so they have this
large accelerated database everything
talks in data frames so when you do a
query you can get back a data frame and
just pass it into one of your algorithms
they can handle you know a petabyte
database pretty easy and if you're
wondering about where to get rapid well
it's pretty much in every cloud system
that's out there google measure you know
I do audio Baba
well Amazon Sage maker so you to start
up a sage maker instance he's this way
to get it
Conda install or download a docker file
so if you want to spin up like a AWS
instance and then just put a docker file
out there we have tutorials blogs
walkthrough everything on our website
I'm kind of a quick peek back at the web
site where you just pick the boxes and
it says you know here's the command to
run to to get things
everything is open-source everything is
on github just go out to our github
account download repos post issues join
in you know all our Doc's are out there
we blog quite a bit about the code so
you just do a search for you know medium
blogs rapid and find everything or we
have a youtube channel also you can find
videos within our github repo we have
two repos dedicated to jupiter notebooks
that are samples of how to do everything
one of them's called notebooks which is
just one notebook per analytic it just
shows how to run that one analytic then
we have notebooks contributes more end
to end problems so if I'm in financial
how do I solve this problem and it goes
over all the steps like I said there's
lots of nice YouTube videos out there
this is showing desk and scaling and you
get these nice desk dashboards with
pretty pictures so please join in the
conversation we have lots of ways to get
in touch with us from you know posting a
github issue you can jump on to our kind
of Google group things and just write a
message say hey this isn't working
we love those things we like to see
people using it asking questions
telling us what your pain point is and
what you would like to see next in the
in the libraries and you're also welcome
to just say hey here's a feature I would
like to write it and just contribute it
back and then it's a standard github
process just clone it write it do a PR
and we'll review it and and kind of it
can be in the next release so join in
the movement contact us let us know what
we can do so with that I'm going to open
it up to questions
[Applause]
hi there thanks for the talk
did you say ucx was the thing of the
desk that was topology aware so you see
X is you can think of it as an extension
to MPI that's topology aware is it
learning the topology of your network
and then applying it or how does it well
I guess topology I'm using it slightly
different it will say yes I know that
your own InfiniBand I won't look at the
entire network I just say ok there Nixon
your machine that are InfiniBand ok or
you're on Ethernet or hey you have env
linked GPUs ok
so I've looked at the integration with
desk and ku DF and it's it seems pretty
seamless you know you just import it and
you're off can you talk a little bit
more about how to integrate with the
deep learning side specifically PI torch
it seems a little bit more difficult to
get into using the data loaders that you
have I'm a punt that one to Dante
yeah yeah so just how to how to canoe
using q DF seems pretty easy using the
data loaders and the batch data loaders
that I've seen seems a little bit more
difficult of a learning curve and
getting those in there maybe I don't
know maybe we need to talk after a bit
like the how would you suggest starting
in the deep learning space dabbling with
what you have there so in general
speaking about the DB learning space
my usual suggestion is that you how
already I am existing code base
particularly something like pi touch is
to exploit the fact that we're very
interpret PI torch so you for example
can use our CSB reader then once your
data is in memory used by PI touch data
loaders to train your deep neural
network for example then that said we
are still improving and I will talk
about it in my talk later so just a
little add we are still improving dated
that that interoperability with data
loader in particular in many ways not
only the KU TF site were also in the
cuomo site so you can have
interoperability for example one of our
it uses and is very popular is people
that have deep learning workflows they
have very complicated neural networks
and when I visualize them for example
with a new map then you don't need to
copy memory or anything you just have
your touch turn so you give it to us we
just process them without much fuss but
it will depend very much on what deep
learning framework we are coming from
and what what is your objective if you
want to have careers that are claiming
is gonna be one type of approach and you
or you if you want to have Co ml
algorithms or cool cool graph algorithms
it's a different type of approach we're
still refining a lot of those
interactions that's it for deep learning
there is not a rapid there's not a
formal like rapid deep learning
component we and I will mention that a
lot more as well the deep learning part
of rapid is actually quite our chain and
all other guys that we collaborate a lot
with it's it's it's we have classical
machine learning which was not there
presently but the deep learning is more
about helping you use what you already
have and not train bending the wheel not
get another deeper learning framework
essentially and we can talk more offline
yet so the answer is attend Dante's talk
okay awesome um let's uh thanks bride
again for the great talk let's give them
another round of applause
[Applause]